to escape briefly the darkness was some
incredible engineering
work uh xai just released grock AI
assistant that I've gotten a chance to
play with it's uh it's amazing on many
levels first of all it's amazing that a
relatively small team in a relatively
short amount of time was able to develop
this close to state-of-the-art system uh
another uh incredible thing is there's a
regular Moe and there's a fun mode yeah
I guess I'm to play for that
one I wish first of all I wish
everything in life had a fun mode yeah I
there's something compelling Beyond just
fun about the fun mode interacting with
a large language model I'm not sure
exactly what it is cuz I only had a
little bit of time to play with it but
it just makes it more interesting more
vibrant to interact with the system yeah
uh absolutely I um our our AI Gro is
modeled after the Hedgehog is Guide to
the Galaxy uh which is one of my
favorite books uh which is it's a book
on philosophy disguises a book on humor
um and
um I would say that is that forms the
basis of My Philosophy uh which is that
we don't know the meaning of life but
the more we can expand the scope and
scale of
Consciousness digital and biological
the more we are able to understand what
questions to ask about the answer that
is the
universe so I have a philosophy of
curiosity there is generally a feeling
like this AI system has an
outward looking like the way you are
like sitting with a good friend looking
up at the stars like the asking pad like
questions about the universe wondering
what it's all about the Curiosity you
talk about there there's a sense no
matter how on day in the question I ask
it there's a sense of cosmic Grandeur to
the whole thing well we are actually
working hard to have uh engineering math
and physics answers that you can count
on
MH um so for the other sort of AIS out
there
that these so-called large language
models um I've not found the uh
engineering to be reliable um and it
hallucination it it unfortunately
hallucinates Mo most when you least want
it to hallucinate yeah so when you ask
important diffic difficult questions it
that's when it tends to be confidently
wrong um so we're really trying hard to
say okay how do we be as grounded as
possible so you can count on the results
um Trace things back to physics first
principles U mathematical logic um so
underlying the humor is an aspiration
to adhere to the truth of the universe
as closely as
possible that's really tricky it is
tricky
so that's why you know you there's
always going to be some amount of error
but do we want to um aspire
to be as truthful as possible about the
answers uh with acknowledged error and
so that there was always you don't want
to be confidently wrong so
not going to be right every time but you
don't you want to minimize how often
you're confidently uh wrong and then
like I said once you can count on the
logic as being
um not violating physics then you can
start to build on that to create uh
inventions like invent new
technologies but if if you can't if you
if you
cannot count on the foundational physics
being correct obviously the inventions
are simply
wishful
thinking you know imagination
land magic
basically